business analyst tools play a crucial
role in helping organizations make
informed decisions and improve their
operations these tools are designed to
collect analyze and visualize data
enabling businesses to gain valuable
insights in this video we will explore
the top 10 business analysis tools that
have become essential for modern
Enterprises from spreadsheets software
to Advanced analytic platforms these
tools offers a wide range of
capabilities to support datadriven
decision making streamline processes and
derive business growth whether you're a
business analyst Enthusiast or a part of
large corporation these tools can help
your business reach its maximum
potential also if you want to become job
ready with globally recognized business
analyst certification course look no
further than simply learn our business
analyst Masters program covers all
aspects of business analysis including
planning and monitoring requirement
elicitation and requirement management
and communication you'll gain expertise
in the latest tools work on real world
projects and attend exclusive master
classes by IBM experts also as a part of
this program I IM jobs will offer
following exclusive program I am jobs
Pro membership for 6 months resume
building assistance Spotlight on I am
jobs for highlighting your profile to
the recruiters elevate your career and
join our business analyst Masters
program today so now let's have a look
at the top 10 business analysis tools
the first one on the list is Trello
Trello is a project management and
collaboration tool that is highly
beneficial for business analyst with its
visual interface analyst can organize
and track tasks projects and workflows
efficiently trellos boards list and card
systems allows analysts to customize
their work structure and easily move
tasks across different stages
collaboration features enable team
members stakeholders and clients to
contribute and provide feedback
integration with other tools enhances
its functionality overall trello's
userfriendly interface flexibility and
collaborative capabilities make it an
essential tool for business analysts to
streamline project management improve
productivity and ensure successful
project delivery now coming to the
second one that is explanting xplan is a
powerful data integration and platform
that allows business analysts to extract
transform and load that is ETL data from
various sources it provides a
userfriendly interface and a wide range
of connectors to help analyst
efficiently manage the process data with
xlent analysts can easily create data
pipelines perform data Transformations
and integrate data from different
systems enabling them to gain valuable
insights and make informed business
decisions next up we have is balsamic
balsamic is a wireframing tool that
helps business analysts create mockups
and prototypes of software applications
or websites it provides a simple and
intuitive interface allowing analysts to
quickly sketch out their ideas and
visualize the user interface balsamic
slow Fidelity wireframes help
stakeholders understand the basic layout
and functionality of the product
facilitating effective communication and
collaboration during the requirements
Gathering phase next tool on the list is
pencil pencil is another wireframing and
prototyping tool that is widely used by
business analysts it offers a range of
inbuilt shapes and templates making it
easy to create interactive mockups and
diagrams pencil supports various diagram
types including flowcharts UI mockups
and network diagrams with pencil
analysts can effectively communicate
their ideas gather feedback and Define
requirements before the development
phase at number five we have is Reich
Reich is a project management and
collaboration tool that plays a crucial
role in the work of business analysts it
allows analysts to create and manage
project tasks track progress and
collaborate with team members in real
time Reich provides features like task
assignment document sharing and Gant
charts enabling analysts to streamline
their work processes ensure timely
delivery of projects and maintain
effective communication with
stakeholders now coming to the sixth
tool on the list which is version one
life cycle version one life cycle is an
agile project management tool that helps
business analyst manage and track
software development projects it
provides a comprehensive set of features
for managing requirements ments tracking
progress and facilitating collaboration
among team members with version one life
cycle analysts can prioritize and manage
user stories track defects and generate
reports ensuring that projects are
delivered on time and within budget now
coming to the seventh tool MS Office
suit the MS office suit including tools
like word excel and PowerPoint is
essential for business analysts these
tool enable analysts to create and
manage documentation perform data
analysis and create visual appealing
presentations word is used for writing
requirement documents Excel for data
analyst and modeling and PowerPoint for
presenting findings and recommendation
to stakeholders the MS office suit is
widely used and provides a familiar and
versatile set of tools for analysts the
next one is rational requisite Pro
rational requisite Pro is a requirement
management tool that helps business
analysts capture organize and Trace
requirements throughout the Project Life
Cycle it allows analysts to Define
requirements link them to business
objectives and track changes and
dependencies rational requisite Pro
provides features like version control
impact analysis and requirement
tracability ensuring that requirements
are effectively managed and aligned with
business goals moving on to the ninth
tool that is smart draw smart draw is a
diagram and visualization tool that is
valuable for business analyst it offers
a wide range of templates and shapes to
create flowcharts process and and
organized charts and other visual
representations smart draws intuitive
interface and automation features make
it easy for analyst to create
professional looking diagrams enhancing
their ability to communicate complex
ideas and processes to stakeholders now
coming to the last tool on the list
which is blueprint blueprint is a
requirement management and collaboration
platform designed specifically for
business analysts it provides a
centralized repository for capturing and
managing and sharing requirements and
show ing that all stakeholders have
access to the latest information
blueprint offers features like
requirement stress ability impact
analysis and collaboration tools
enabling analysts to effectively manage
requirements and ensure alignment with
business objectives the world of
business analysis tools is vast and
dynamic offering a wide range of options
to help individuals and organizations
make sense of their data and make
informed decisions we have explored the
top 10 business analysis Tools in this
video each with its unique strengths and
capabilities
whether you're a data Enthusiast a small
business owner or a part of large
corporation these tools are your alleys
in the Quest for deeper insights
streamlined operations and ultimately
success in a data Riven world all right
guys with that we have come to the end
of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here